you know I like to find really effective
strategies to increase your survival
your health without spending a lot of
money and that's what this video is
about unfortunately our environment is
just very very polluted uh we are being
bathed in chemicals and heavy metals is
one of the toxins that we're exposed to
I'm talking about Mercury lead cadmium
Arsenic and these heavy metals can
accumulate in our tissues they can cross
the blood-brain barrier they can affect
the heart your digestive system your
neurons your red blood cells that can
make you anemic they can attack the ATP
and make you tired they actually affect
certain proteins and they block certain
proteins like for example the proteins
that allow you to grow hair so one of
the side effects would be hair loss and
these heavy metals also create a lot of
free radicals a lot of oxidation and
they force our own antioxidants to work
harder but not only that heavy metals
tend to block our own it's called
endogenous antioxidants now our bodies
already have a very powerful
detoxification system it comes from
within the same thing with our immune
system we have an immune system that can
actually fight off things but of course
so many people are trying to sterilize
the environment and ignoring their own
immune system well the same thing occurs
with heavy metals you can avoid them to
a certain degree for sure but you should
also know about how to strengthen as a
really smart strategy your detox enzymes
okay I'm talking about glutathione I'm
talking about sod which stands for
superoxide dismutase these are enzymes
that help you break down chemicals
they're also going to help you prevent
oxidation and also prevent free radical
damage and the problem is the heavy
metals block these systems just like for
example antibiotics greatly reduce your
immune system and I'm talking about the
chemicals from pollution water air food
certain fish shellfish loaded with
Mercury and the younger you are the more
highly susceptible you are to the damage
so it just so happens there are some
natural herbs that you can tap into
to not only
detoxify by chelation and chelation
means you're binding something with the
heavy metal and removing it through the
system but not only that they have the
ability to up regulate or turn up as a
dial your own enzymes that detoxify so
the genes that control detoxification
can be upregulated by what I'm going to
talk about next now this is really cool
because these herbs can very easily be
added to your diet with very little
expense and just as a part of a healthy
lifestyle you don't have to even buy any
supplements you just put a little bit of
this into your food on a regular basis
so the first one is sulforaphane in
broccoli Sprouts but especially broccoli
micro greens which are basically Sprouts
that have grown a little bit bigger I
would definitely recommend growing your
own and I'm going to be doing some
videos on that and if you get broccoli
micro grains ideally if you can get them
grown in soil that would be the ideal
situation but but even if you get them
to Sprouts you're going to get good
amounts of sulforaphane so broccoli
spouts doesn't take much a little bit in
your salad a few times a week that's all
you need to do remember these Sprouts
are like 20 to 40 to 50 to even 100
times
more concentrated than adult broccoli it
means you don't need much to create the
effect the next herb and it's also
considered a spice which is very
powerful is cilantro in the UK it's
known as coriander but cilantro has been
around for a very very long time it was
even found in the Tomb of King Tut
there's also some powerful research that
can act as a powerful
anti-convulsant for those people who
have seizures but cilantro is used in a
lot of different recipes it's in Thai
recipes it's in salsa certain Indian
dishes in guacamole so I would encourage
you just use more cilantro in your food
because it can act as a powerful
chelator with virtually zero side
effects it can act as an antioxidant to
reduce the free radicals and it can also
upregulate your detoxification genes to
get rid of these heavy metals and other
poisons and then we have all Allison in
garlic garlic is a very potent chelator
and it's also a potent up regulator of
the detoxification genes cure cumin okay
in turmeric is another one and of course
you have the cruciferous vegetables can
also help now of course to avoid heavy
metals you're right I don't know what
island you'd have to live on but you can
at least start doing more organic and
you can get a really good water filter
to help eliminate some of the toxicity
that you're exposed to now since I
mentioned Mercury which is a very common
heavy metal that we're exposed to if you
have not seen my video on how to reduce
the mercury in the fish that you eat I
put that video right up here check it
out